so this behavior of bacteria working in
groups we now call that quorum sensing
and so the way it works is bacteria need
to understand times when they're alone
and times when they're in communities so
that they can behave differently when
they're alone and when they're in the
group and so the way that they do that
they can't see and they can't really
talk and so the way bacteria know when
they're alone or when they're neighbors
is that they make and release small
molecules so as the bacteria grow and
double in number they're all releasing
these molecules into the environment so
the more cells there are the more of the
molecule there is and when that molecule
hits a particular threshold amount the
bacteria detected and they infer from
that detection event that they must have
neighbors around and so in unison all of
the bacteria changed their behavior
together
so that's quorum sensing it's a chemical
communication mechanism that allows
bacteria to orchestrate group behaviors
you